puis ma prime à jeter
[Musique]
on m'a dit un jour tu trouveras un
boulot ou tard a envie de te lever pour
ça c'est exactement ce qui se passe
[Musique]
j'ai vraiment commencé à me plonger dans
une vidéo bon qu'il ya eu les pokémon
forcément sur gameboy color mais le vrai
truc hardcore qui est arrivé c'est à
l'âge de 9 ans avec world of warcraft
quand elle a un taux n'a gagné tu vois
je faisais le volant les persos c'était
très dans la fantaisie et moi j'adore la
fantaisie et le fantastique et du coup
bah je sais pas si je me sentais bien
dans cet univers est en fête bat comme
j'étais plus jeune je n'étais plus ronde
et j'avais beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'acné bien du coup à l'école ça se
passait pas très bien je me battais
beaucoup et du coup on fait un mot comme
ton personnage pour moi ton personnage
était beau bat cette chute était
derrière ton personnage est en mode bas
je suis sacrément bien et je suis stylet
et c'est là est en fait où tu commences
à te faire des amis
j'étais colère est écoulé ouest et
qu'elle est restée collée au risque
ma mère a toujours joué un peu tout ce
qui était nintendo mon père tomb raider
mon nom c'était en judée aussi mais
parce que par plaisir et en fait ça les
a pas choqué on va dire que moi je parte
là dedans
et du coup bah enfin je sais pas ils ont
jamais été
tu vois paniquer sur le fait que je joue
beaucoup
j'avais une prof ma prof de littérature
étrangère en terminale qui dit que je
serai une bonne à rien parce que je suis
invité bases en anglais et avait dit je
serai une bonne à rien je réussirai à
rien dans ma vie et bah un an plus tard
je suis parti en angleterre et
aujourd'hui j'en suis où j'en suis mais
du coup c'est difficile parce que tu
avais plein de profs qui peuvent
rabaissé et ça arrive à plein de gens et
j'en sais je trouve ça ouais je ne sais
pas mais j'ai un problème avec les cours
et la façon d'apprentissage est un
en fait la première chose qu'on m'a dit
1 toute première c'est regarde pas le
chat parce que tu es une fille est en
bonne voie
pourquoi tu vois et j'ai trouvé ma tête
parce qu'il avait le chat l'âge étant
rattachée au code ce têt et genre
c'était horrible horrible leschi que
l'on prend des gens elle est bonne c'est
une fille elle est dégueulasse et lima
il le chiévo possible et c'était
choquant parce que moi qui ai eu du mal
à l'école à me prendre des réflexions
comme ça j'ai vendu castagne de moins
badiou première chose que j'ai faite
quand on m'a fait ouvrir mon type en
twitter j'ai commencé à répondre mais
super méchamment à des gens 20 genre
vraiment comme je fais dans la vraie vie
tu vois et on m'a dit il faut se calmer
parce que bon c'est voit la fin en gros
tu vas et tu vas avoir une image fausse
tenir un petit peu et quand je suis
arrivé à éclipse ya si je suis arrivé
comme c'est aujourd'hui si tu veux tu
certes un peu large et j'avais mutisme
et tee shirt de jeux vidéo vrai convoqué
dans l'aude d'euros de patron pour me
dire gilles tenait pas assez féminin il
va falloir que tu t'habilles féminine
des jeux 3d
ok et lors d'une réunion il perçait cas
par cas et c'est machin oui toi c'est
bien tu as tant de temps et moi quand il
passe à moi il fait toutes façons toi
c'est normal que tu as des abonnés
cuisine mais tu es là pour te montrer sa
next direct tu vois et je tends mode
alors les autres ils ont des
félicitations
mais oui tu es un bon animateur ou était
simitis à moi j'étais vraiment genre
l'objet la plante verte aujourd'hui
lorsque les gros doigts
[Musique]
maintenant je sais ce que je veux
vraiment dans la vie et show mode je
vais tout faire pour y arriver que ce
soit alexandra odile de toute façon
puisque tu en a beaucoup qui peut-être
vont jouer un personnage différent
peut-être un peu plus doux peut-être un
peu plus liste c'est un peu machin et
moi genre pas vraiment je suis un peu
pas enfin je suis globalement c'est là
c'est la balance ou pareil dans la vraie
vie que dans mon
dans mon stream je pense que j'y vois là
est en mode ouais c'est bon c'est ça tu
peux y aller bien le bonjour à tous
merci infiniment pour tout votre soutien
comme d'habitude construit mais j'ai
quand même instauré le pa2 que soient
positifs ou négatifs pas de
de réflexion sur le physique que ce soit
un très bel ou un thé moche c'est banni
par f1 c'est time out pareil c'est 10
minutes parce que c'est écrit dans les
règles j'ai pas envie qu'on vient de me
dire à tes jolies ou machin ou as tu es
moche ou ata sykora taza vraiment moi je
suis vraiment dans le mode ne vois pas
mon physique vous voit plus loin que le
physique d'ange la gâteau adios amigos
en toi alors que gilles gauvin pour la
première fois en quatre ans j'ai pris
une semaine c'était en fin d'année parce
que on m'a obligé
c'était vraiment c'était la porte sûrs
quand on m'a dit tu dois prendre des
vacances
maintenant je ne veux pas avoir de
vacances parce que je me fais chier sans
magouille étais tu vois ce rendez-vous
du matin c'est important que mon père
m'a toujours dit dans ta vie tu fais le
passé le travail avant tout les trucs de
ta vie à la famille etc
mais c'est pas l'amour qui va te payer
le loyer c'est pas l'amitié qui va te
payer le loyer c'est toi c'est ta
réussite et mon père m'a et ma mère
aussi m'ont toujours inculqué qu' il
faut que tu travailles pour te
débrouiller et réussir peu importe que
j'ai fait c'est en mode ou est évasive
mais si tu y vas tu le fais à fond ça va
faire tout noir